[Music]
we often hear that public universities
charge higher and higher tuition and
state policymakers have cut their
funding some say than the way to bring
tuition down is to bring government
funding up yet most research finds that
when state governments cut or increased
funding public universities the effect
on tuition is quite weak one rigorous
study found that for every additional
dollar public universities received from
taxpayers tuition decline by only 26
cents so where's the money going well
for one the university could allocate a
budget increase to boost its own
spending on new programs and services in
this case funding goes up and university
spending goes up so tuitions stays the
same now consider a university facing
budget cuts 1 2018 study found that
universities often reduced their own
spending instead of passing all the
budget cuts on to students through
higher tuition the bottom line is not
all funding cuts are bad and not all
funding increases make tuition more
affordable what do you think is driving
tuition increases let us know in your
comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI